pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing
company dedicated to making the very
best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to
wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com
pogchimps
okay but how is code miko playing so
well knight e5
here that is great she put her knight
towards the center she is playing
quickly
oh and the games have started we have
code miko with the white pieces versus
mr beast with the black and he's playing
yet another
scandinavian honestly uh the video that
gotham chess put on his youtube
explaining the preparation was very well
done if any of you guys want to see what
happens before these games
um speaking of gambling
the predictions are open on chess
dot com slash salary touchdown tv slash
chess
so if you want to go vote for who is
going to win make sure you're putting
your points to get use
right i mean i'm actually very impressed
with code miko's plate
she's not even saying anything which is
pretty cool because that means that the
technician who is
actually no of course it's code miko the
v tubers are real though the technician
who's playing
is so focused that usually she's talking
non-stop
she is innovating she's making content
but right now she's super focused and
i i really respect how both players are
handling this so
oh no alex how did you how could you
leak that you guys
you know what santa claus isn't real a
lot of parents get divorced it's over 50
now and yes there's a technician okay
ruined everyone's day let's continue
her pieces are more active than blacks
she also has her pawns more forward
towards black's king and mr beast hasn't
yet pushed
the pawns that would be a threat towards
her king's side not to mention
the bishop on f8 which is still not
developed yet e6 is still a natural move
but there's not a ton of good places for
him to put his bishop
okay but how is code miko playing so
well
95 here that is great she put her knight
towards the center she is playing
quickly
oh no no commentators curse both has
gambit it happens
uh and mr beast took it right away so oh
what
god damn it i did not see that
sorry it's okay guys it's okay it's okay
don't worry don't worry
don't worry it's okay
okay mr beast takes the pawn on c3 and
drops his queen
vote and damn it too powerful let's go
yes i'm inflexible glad that you got the
chance to commentate on this game
because
it is the botus gambit special i mean if
there's any better way
to like describe a game in one word or
two words rather it's the bonus gambit
we see the queen giving back
um if komiko plays rectangular
codemico has to see it so let's see what
she's arrowing i don't think she's
talking because she's thinking
i don't like that oh no no no no not
rook the eight
not rook d8 no and then i
it's good that she's calculating she has
time and mr beast needs to think on her
time as well
i'm gonna try oh my god over there
[Applause]
no miss click oh yeah
oh my god let's go let's go back on the
full screen because mr beast just well i
guess we missed it but he gave a sigh
he looked so relieved he did i'm just
going to reenact what he did
maybe not that dramatic but you get what
i mean oh no
and now the bishop is gone now it's all
going downhill
yeah he's just gonna go straight for the
second queen
he still has seven pawns on the board
pathway so technically if you want it he
could promote
the rest of those spots too and then get
eight queens however
i don't think mr beast would do that
that is however something i would love
to do in a bullet game at some point i
mean he could do it and then
name his next youtube title like i have
seven pawns but i donate them all to
code miko
that would be a fun one yeah definitely
just do it for content right
exactly i mean it's a content brain i'd
love to see it
okay i want to see him finish off with
the latter he has so many checkmates
here
yeah just there's not even a chance for
still mate because white still has the
g-pawn
right well i will say it was very
impressive how he kept his cool
throughout the game and even though he
was really low on time he was still
calculating and he didn't seem nervous
at all
yeah i think um you know he's he's
successfully
ladder checkmated his rating is now 700
exact
no okay the second game that has started
so mr beast versus code miko mr beast is
the favorite to win and he has the white
pieces
but code miko played very well minus the
uh queen blunder and the miss click in
the first game
that miss click was so sad because if
she had just misclicked a little bit
more
she would have actually gotten the queen
that was very unfortunate
but we're good what is um
since ludwig is watching and he's trying
to get tips ludwig don't do this so that
you don't lose to moist critical again
you're welcome
yeah code miko can definitely uh
come back from this and she does see
knight c6
which would lead her to be able to
capture the pawn next move but her
bishop is hanging and she needs to worry
about that
first right so her bishop
she can take on c3 which oh
okay well the problem with this is that
she's gonna give up another pawn if mr
beast
takes the bishop she captures the knight
which is good that she doesn't lose a
full piece
but then b takes c3 he gobbles up yet
another pawn and then if the queens are
traded well at least neither of them can
blunder it
but that will be a better end game for
mr b i do actually wonder
like where does he think his knight
should go because sometimes it's
actually difficult for
for newer players oh no
oh that one is a little bit painful
maybe
he okay so he calculated this and
he think it seems like he's okay with it
i'm not sure
why but he still has decent chances if
he can develop his pieces
anything could happen anything could
happen anything could happen i think
he was able to get a pawn back um and at
this point
the problem is he still doesn't have any
past pawns whereas code miko has the
entire a pawn
yeah ooh b5 so that's just a free
pawn but
i think code miko's instincts of pushing
the pawns towards the queen side of the
board is the correct strategy it was
just the wrong pawn it was like pick any
pawn
one's good one's bad yeah one's good
one's bad
but nobody's taking the pause while
nobody's taking the boss
why whoa oh my god this game i don't
understand this game
look nemo it is too high level for us to
understand
these are genius content creators at
play
so that's that's what's going on here
oh my gosh somebody in the chess.com
chat said this is the weirdest game of
chess i have ever seen
in my life but that's why it's fun and
that's why i love
watching them look mr beast got under 30
seconds last time or under a minute
so he is being very careful with his
time which i respect and code miko is
now threatening rook b1
he has to see this he has to see this
but what he has done well is play a lot
faster so he didn't see the perfect move
which was king c2 but he saw a good move
which was rookie one and when you're low
like this
that's oh now she now he can take on e6
and if he sees this um you know he's
back in the game and he gets to keep his
rook
on the board so mr beast is taking his
time here which makes me think that
he's not going to miss bishop e6 because
he also sees his bishop under attack so
he takes it
oh my gosh kodamiko has eight times the
amount of time he has almost
honestly she's been playing pretty
intuitively i think she has a lot of
potential
if she just plays a little bit more you
know and it'd be very interesting
to see both of these players oh no
not that place not that square oh and
she can't even take it back because of
the pin
that is so rough however mr beast only
has
15 seconds i don't know if he will see
it
[Music]
don't flag i don't want to see a flag
come on i can't
oh no okay
oh no now not only
is the just the rock hanging the knight
on e7 is also hanging and mr beast has
decided to take
the knight on e7 all right well
it's good that he got a piece that is
great
um rook g7 just played that was a quick
move she got it away from the threat so
that is what we like to see
and mr beast is picking it up oh my gosh
chad do you guys think mr beast is going
to flag or is he going to survive his
her rook doesn't have any safe place
except for g6 which she saw
oh two seconds oh
my heart and now he has 6.9 seconds that
is
nice perfectly timed sir perfect nice
alex
nice and we have 69 000 viewers i'm just
saying that's obviously why he's
matching it okay
obviously obviously it's for oh it's all
for youtube you know
oh okay i think there's a little bit of
a lag he hasn't flagged this game okay
i would have really liked to see rick
the d2 as we okay well
she has the right idea unfortunately
wrong execution rooks on the second are
the most strong in end games
take the juicer let's go
uh oh oh no
maybe she's going for the stalemate
strat or the oh
okay we're not taking the pieces that's
fine oh but she does get the pawn on h2
i
mr p should really at this point just
either push the pawn or play bishop e5
to win the rook but i think e7 is a very
natural move
just just you know try to promote he's
handling the pressure so well
yeah i mean just playing with increment
is very difficult but he's making sure
he
he does think a little bit before each
move and just not running out of time
and now there's nothing that she can do
to stop e8 he'll throw in a couple more
checks which is nice
okay and he's got this checkmate
checkmate technique down that was a
really impressive comeback from mr beast
for sure i think he's gonna try to go
for the ladder mate either yep
probably see something like rook to e3
oh
oh we even take the rook first okay now
i'm just a little bit worried about
stillman but he does know the latter
checkmate so should not be too much of
an issue for him
there's that excitement on his face okay
he has checkmate in two here
even if he doesn't find it like that um
there's not a lot that can go wrong here
so all right and we are seeing
the latter checkmate wow
code miko you put up a great fight and
mr beast congratulations for going 2-0
how are you feeling
well i mean you can tell we're both uh
still getting the hang of chess
and learning i have a feeling there
there's quite a few blunders that last
game but
yeah i mean it feels good not to lose
every single game i've played now
that's fair enough and code miko we
noticed that you were playing super
quickly and often when you were playing
quickly you were making some of the best
moves
can you tell us a little bit more do you
have really good chess instinct
um i think if i had the chess winston
instinct i would win a game no
you're like an ai you just need a little
bit more data points and then you'll
start winning
right you think so yeah yeah i just need
to do more chess
oh just more chess honestly you were
doing really great in the last game like
we felt a large amount of improvement
even from your first game today in your
second game because in your second game
you were finding all these very natural
ideas straight out of the opening
you know you were going for some really
accurate tactics you had the right idea
when you
started playing you know your night to
uh night up the board knight to c2 all
of that was really good
i do have a question miko so what did
you notice when you mouse slipped you
could have taken mr beast's queen
[Laughter]
yeah that was a misclick
i feel so bad i know that's why like
that win doesn't even feel satisfying
because i
literally left my queen hanging uh and
didn't get punished for it so i kind of
feel bad about that
well speaking of not getting punished
you were making us so nervous because
you kept getting to under
one minute on the clock do you do you
need to live
under pressure because you want to play
really well i feel like my clock just
goes five times faster like i'll look
it'll be four minutes and then i'll
think for five seconds and i look down
it's on like 30 seconds i'm like where
did it go
yeah code miko has has been doing some
hackerman's maybe
both of you will be going into the
consolation bracket and you
will be playing against the other
members who maybe have played a little
bit less chess than people in the
championship bracket
so how are you guys feeling your chances
are maybe we'll start with code miko and
then mr beast
i think i have a chance
yes yes let's go i like this
i think that there is a chance that i
can win one of those
that is the optimism we're here for what
about you mr beast
i started off with ludwig and moist who
have played in pogchamps before have
chess coaches
and have played like 10 times the amount
of games of chess that i have
so i'm just excited to play people that
just don't have this massive head start
and have training and all this stuff i
literally was just like an hour before
my match with luge wig i was like
hey gotham can you just teach me a few
things whereas he's been training for
for years trying to go for the dub so
yeah
that'd be fun and and it's motivated me
uh this year obviously
i'm already in the constellation
brackets i'm back it doesn't matter but
next year i want to try to make a run
for it it'll be fun
[Music]
you